said a lot about the role of the media
enough so called eric democracy
hi i'm wondering how you see here are
the rollover educational system what
it's doing right now what forces are
driving at
and what constraints are and how should
operate
we are
i quoted the uh... trilateral commission
view of the educational system
namely to system of indoctrination of
the young
and i think that's correct
to system of indoctrination linux
that was the way the liberal
deletes regarded and they're more or
less accurate
uh... so the educational system is
supposed to train people to be uh...
obedient conformist
not drink too much sugar which told me
state passive
don't cause any price is a democracy or
raise any questions and so on that's
basically what the
what the uh... system is about
uh... they even the fact that the system
has a lot of stupidity and i think as a
function
you know it means that
people are filtered out for opinions
if you can guarantee lots of stupidity
and the educational system you know like
stupid assignments and things like that
you know that the only people who will
make it through
are people like me unlike most eli
guests
who are willing to do it no matter how
stupid it is because
over the next step
so you may know that this assignment is
idiotic and i got there couldn't
because we had a paper bag
but he'll do it anyway
because that's the way you get to the
next question
needed my make it and so on and so forth
well there are people who don't do that
now there are people who say i'm going
to do it through the cutest thing
uh... those people are called behavioral
problem
something like that they end up in the
principles officer in the streets are
selling drugs or whatever
and all of this is a technique for
uh... selection for obedience
i dot approved this but i have a feeling
that when you go to the ailing
universities
you find more obedience and conformity
probably because you're getting the
students who were
better able to do it
uh... were all that is functional that's
the way it works for it
and it works right through
graduate school
i mean if you they're upsetting but how
do you graduate schools or a little more
varied because some real contradictions
development system
the problem is that you can't
progress this way
na na especially in the sciences and
engineering that's prob
because the corporations need
science and engineering
he don't have
innovation you're really in trouble
so they have to encourage creativity in
independence
'cause he can't
get anywhere if you just copy what
somebody told me
you have to be challenging things all
the time
challenging everything you know
i'm thinking who sought some song and
they are real contradiction
uh... it's hard to train people to be
creative and challenging and so on and
yet that i'm sure that somewhere else in
their lives their conformist an obedient
in everything
so you have problems that's a serious
problem in japan
uh... we think of japan as miss
tremendous superpower but that's very
misleading
japan for example is very poor
nowhere
and part of the reason is it such as
part of its part the same thing that
makes them good workers obedient workers
to very obedient society very
deferential and conformist society
and one effect of that is that you
you know there are real constraints
against
independent free said thinking you see
it in the science is very clearly
the uh...
but from here to so there are those
contradictions when you get the graduate
school are beginning to show up they
show up much less than the ideological
subjects
because there doesn't matter too much of
people have
there there is no profits aren't made
buddy historians having original ideas
but french revolution
so they can have conventional ideas
and that means that the
the pressure to try to support
innovation and freedom is much less in
the profession
the pressures for conformity on the
other hand are much greater
cousin the ideological subject it begins
to be dangerous to people think the
wrongful
dangerous if they have new ideas about
physics
uh... so saying it but nevertheless you
know you do there's you begin to get a
little flocks of the system by the time
graduate school
and even at low levels you find it i
mean there's
you know there are teachers who do
stimulate thought
and sometimes they get away with
and uh... you know all the way through
you know if you feel
learning things he just needs can
control you can't make them just
regurgitate
what they heard
now there's a lot of pressure to turn
the schools into the marine corps
lends a lot of support for
the for example is this bestseller
last couple years by allan bloom
that was all over the supermarkets
closing the american mine
whichever you know huge bestseller
supermarket racks which is where i read
it and things like that
greater cooperation
at at the end of tight you know a lot of
suggesting accolades for it and so on
uh... he was saying that
a couple of uh... smart guys will decide
what the great thoughts are
uh... and every student memorizing
as education
we are no and that's the way to turn
people into pure comedy
i mean even if they happen to pick the
great thoughts
uh... there is no way less
likely to get anybody to think about
those thoughts than to make that the
curriculum
that finishes amok
that uh...
and i think that's the purpose for them
i mean the purposes just to impose fire
no
here's a great for us
also stuff is rubbish just learners here
okay
opic can you memorize
that's basically the line
now of course that's that's the opposite
of education
now that's the latest study thoma or
something like that
uh... but uh...
it's very popular and i think it
reflects the same concern over the
crisis of my person
background
lemon selfless
extreme of the incident that really got
them was a case in
cornell where he was a professor
where some black students took over one
of the admins buildings
and he would he said that's just like
not to give us back to the nazis is old
business but the nazis and so on and so
forth
where you take a little it happened and
that you can tell you what he thought
the and its effect on the capitulated
not just like i did hear which would not
to be subsumed
that what actually happened if you look
back is that there were real grievances
undoubtedly that students should love
them but they didn't go in the building
with guns and so on but it was settled
react
it was so that we have to remember he
was killed
uh... the grievances were to some extent
dealt with on the net result was better
that was before
but he doesn't really thought they
should have
mozart and president clinton
i guess they should have
bombed the place or something like that
that's really set him off and in general
what set many people off was the day
you know the the sixties are now
described
in the literature as if it was a time
when students were running around
burning libraries and
you know destroying the foundations of
civilization and so on
what was actually going on as they were
asking questions
you know they were raising questions
they were uh...
looking into things appeal and looked
into before they were not just a billion
and from the point of view of the log
faculty that's equivalent to bring that
building
weekend that small distinction can make
that
and the
http pressured return schools back to
the days when you have to worry about
those things like disobedient students
asking questions about things that you
don't think about